what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our trend covering
some older Iron Man stuff we actually
pick up with a story called the secret
origin of Tony Stark now technically
speaking this was something like 12
issues long and it's actually split into
like three or four different storylines
in the first part it's like three issues
and then three issues and those are two
story arcs and then the second part it's
like four issues and two issues another
two story arcs but we're not gonna worry
about all that we're just gonna kind of
finish the first two and then go to the
second two and then call it a day so
it'll make sense as we go through it and
in fact you really won't even notice the
transition from one storyline to another
but the cool thing about this one is
that remember this is when Tony Stark
had basically taken off from Earth and
joined the guardians of the galaxy for
time and then he actually ended up
defecting from the guardians of the
galaxy so what this does is this
actually picks up in the aftermath of
the Avengers vs. x-men storyline now
basically that story just dealt with the
idea of the return of the Phoenix force
now that whole Avengers vs. x-men
storyline branched out into a litany of
different things the fact remains that
with Tony Stark after the events of
Avengers vs. x-men he had basically just
kind of bailed out and so what this does
is show us that there are galaxies
sweeping ramifications for the things
that go on with regards to planet Earth
and the things that various heroes do
and so of course but Tony Stark kind of
you know being really chatty talking up
a you know a woman from a different
world what's kind of cool about this is
that this is a group called the baldies
and they are really kind of like the the
harbingers of a lot of different races
that have existed over the years in
Marvel Comics and in fact that's really
kind of what Karen Gillan's throwing in
here it's a little bit of a red con in
terms of the different races in Marvel
whether it's like the Shiar or the Kree
or the scroll or whatever the case they
maybe we always kind of assumed they
just evolved in their own section of the
universe in a lot of ways they did but
what this story about the vol D does is
it tells us that somewhere along the
line they came into contact with the
Shiar which is why the Shiar looked like
the baldy they dressed like the vaulty
the fashion aspect imprinted on them
there were other elements of their own
society that imprinted on the Kree and
on the the Skrulls and so on and so
forth and so it's one of these things
where well I wouldn't say the vol d were
like Raj inators for all beings in
existence their role within the universe
certainly helped to influence other
races around the universe in terms of
their evolution and how they progressed
the funny thing about this is that this
chicks like one of those crazy religious
girls but for Tony it's really just kind
of like one
one of those one offs you know we're
like you get whether the new bail and
you never have to deal with her
craziness the problem with this is that
when she sees what he looks like under
his mask she freaks out and she just
starts reading him the riot act she's
just like you're hideous under your mask
which really kind of sucks and it really
gotta blows because he was expecting you
know to have a happy ending to the night
when she doesn't really get but
ultimately he's basically attacked by
the baldy directly at least by some of
their cops and brought before their high
priestess and what we end up finding out
is that the voldie like so many other
races across the Marvel Universe
especially that she are basically
worshipped the Phoenix force and so the
idea here is that because Tony Stark and
the earth-based superheroes effectively
destroyed the Phoenix force he is going
to be held accountable for that crime in
particular now what this does is this
actually brings in a character called
recorder four five one now the recorders
are created by a by a race called the
Rogell ian's and in fact they actually
date all the way back to 1966 with for
number 129 which is when they were first
introduced and what's funny about that
because they're really just kind of
coming out of it their introduction
actually centers around ego the Living
Planet which is really kind of
interesting it's really kind of funny
how it all ties together but back when
ego first popped up in Marvel Comics he
was just like a sentient planet that
just existed in this place called the
black galaxy and they called it that way
because everything that came into
contact her came into that galaxy was
basically absorbed and ingested by ego
the Living Planet to both provide him
with the energy he needs as well as
absorb their knowledge and expand his
own intelligence now of course this
eventually dead ended into a story worth
for and Galactus fought ego and the
Galactus just like strapped a rocket to
his back-end and sent him just hurling
across the universe it was weird but the
fact remains that the Rogell ian's were
really more of like explorers and
colonizers and so the idea was that if
the black galaxy is there an ego the
Living Planet threatens their existence
their goal was to essentially go out and
explore the rest of the cosmos in order
to find other worlds to settle on and to
do this they created recorders and the
recorders are basically these robots
that would just go out they're more or
less probes they would go out they would
explore some predetermined destination
in space they would report back their
memories would be wiped and they would
repeat the process that's all of they
would do well this particular guy for 51
for reasons that are not initially given
to us and in fact reasons I don't even
think are given to us at all for
whatever reason he
didn't go back and instead he just kept
exploring the cosmos and so he's been
around for millennia and basically just
seen everything there is to see and so
we're actually gonna find out that he
plays a major role in the whole secret
origin of Tony Stark but 4:51 just kind
of showing up and talking to Tony Stark
is done for the purpose of actually
breaking him out of jail or at least
trying to find a way to get him out of
there and so what happens is once he's
brought before this Tribunal more or
less he basically demands trial by
combat and in doing so he's paired up
against you know a handful of different
people now all the different trials he
goes through all different battles he
goes through are done for the charges
he's facing and he's facing dozens and
dozens of charges you know destroying a
deity heresy against the baldy and you
know just being a dick I mean there's
all different kinds of charges that he's
like that he's facing here and so
because of that he actually ends up
going against a multitude of different
foes and beating every last one of them
now the reason why is because of the
fact that while Tony Stark himself has
no real combat abilities the voldy race
as a whole doesn't fight they're not a
conflicting Society they're very much
like Noir and rads race before he became
the Silver Surfer II those individuals
who basically sought out so just kind of
engage in peace and study you know
really more of like arts and so on and
so forth as opposed to conflict there's
a bunch of hippies so because of that
Tony Stark's able to take out almost
every last one of these guys just
because of the fact that in his own
escapades as an Avenger he's able to
hold his own but because of the fact
that he's able to defeat all of these
guys one is up happening is the vol D
call in someone called death's head now
deaths head was created by a guy named
Simon Furman and this is actually a
really cool story Simon Furman was
working for Marvel's UK imprint back in
the 1960s or 70s and that was basically
Marvel's attempt to branch out into the
United Kingdom into England and create
stories that people would care about
that's where like Captain Britain came
from and the scallop er team and all
that kind of stuff but the fact remains
here that deaths head was created as a
transformers character and Simon Furman
actually threw him in the transformers
comics the problem was that at the time
comic books were becoming more and more
popular and the Transformers were
growing into their own by quite a huge
margin I mean it was like issue number
one hundred and something by the time
that by the time the 1960s rolled around
and so because of that the fear was that
if deaths had stayed in the Transformers
comics exclusively then he would
basically become a transformers property
and so because of that Marvel would
essentially lose
rights to him because back then it was
kind of like create her own conscience
so if a guy made something and threw it
into a comic so long as it stays in that
line of comics it becomes the property
of that line of comics and so what
Marvel did is they actually cranked out
this super quick like one shot that
basically had death's head inside a
Marvel comic which in turn MIT Marvel
could say now he's the exclusive
property of us they in turn filed a
copyright claim on death's head and then
made death's head a Marvel character so
it was really kind of cool the way they
pulled that off it was like she Hulk
right like they wanted to do she-hulk in
the TV show so Marvel cranked out a
comic to make she-hulk a Marvel
character and so then they had to go and
just get permission from Marvel in order
to include her in and Marvel got all the
money from the she-hulk appearances that
ever showed out outside of the comic
books but the fact remains a
death's-head is basically just a giant
robot he's really a bounty hunter but
standing some 30 feet tall he's a lot
more powerful than Tony Stark is so
again it's actually kind of crazy now
something else to point out here is that
Tony Stark is forced to fight without
his armor and even those individuals
that he's going against are forced to
fight without weapons so it's actually
kind of a cool little little tidbit here
but the fact remains that with him more
or less being saved this comes by way of
his new AI called pepper which is
basically just a way to maintain his
connection to Pepper Potts when he's out
in space it's a totally Savio as an
autonomous AI it's not really Pepper
Potts it's just kind of modeled after
her but the way the recorder 451 breaks
Tony Stark out is by capturing something
called the heart of the vol D and
basically this is a massive energy
source the vaulty used to keep their
society going and to keep their energies
going and does so by basically feeding
on the excess energy of the Celestials
and various other cosmic entities in the
Marvel Universe
well the Celestials are none too happy
about that and apparently they've been
searching around for the baldy forever
with the heart of the voldie they were
able to keep themselves basically hidden
and protected with the heart of the vol
D gone the Celestials obliterate the
entire place it is going to show up out
of nowhere and destroy everything so
it's actually pretty wild and it's
pretty messed up but ultimately Tony saw
it just kind of has to leave it's gonna
has to let him go and fly off and so
what this does is it leads to him coming
into direct contact with death's head
himself now of course deaths head it
basically was kind of bailed out when
everything was going a pot when it all
was kind of going to pieces but recorder
451 basically kind of took off and then
kind of poked fun at Tony Stark a little
bit like hey you know catch me if you
can that kind of a thing well the
universe is a massive place and so
because of that Tony Stark a line
self alongside death's-head will give
them resources to like the kind of
things that bounty hunters only have and
he's eventually able to track down
recorder four or five one what we end up
fighting out here though is that record
of four or five one basically set all
this up four five one essentially as
soon as Tony Stark and death's-head show
up recorder four five one packs and two
Tony starts soon' takes control of his
AI and then it also turns out that he
had basically paid death's-head to lead
Tony Stark here in the first place and
so the reason why is because of the fact
that recorder had to create a
circumstance where Tony Stark would come
to him and the reason for that is
because record a 4-5-1 has a very
important piece of information
this piece of information being a
message directly from Tony Stark's
father and so the crazy thing about this
is that Tony Stark's just kind of made
to watch just because of the fact that
recorder has control of his armor and
that kind of thing and start really
can't leave but initially we're not told
exactly what it is
that his father said instead we're just
kind of like given this jump over where
it's just like okay and that's what he
said and of course Tony Stark's kind of
reacting to it and freaking out but what
we end up finding out here is that the
parents of Tony Stark had a very hard
time conceiving Howard ámoreá just could
not conceive a child and so much like
dr. strange trying to find a way to heal
his hands Howard is are traveling around
to various people and this is kind of
cool because it's a lot of the most
intelligent scientific people in the
Roman Marvel Comics but they deal mostly
with biology more so than anything else
the Eternal City you know we're all the
Eternals live you know these basically
angelic like beings in the Marvel
Universe don't really have a way to save
it the High Evolutionary a guy that
basically deals with growing human
beings cannot do anything to help them
now the fact remains that we actually
end up picking up with Howard Stark kind
of falling to the bottom of the barrel
where a guy's like hey man I know a guy
who knows a guy who knows a guy and this
leads him to Las Vegas Nevada where he
comes into contact with this guy who's
basically a great now as far as I'm
aware this is the first appearance of
their race inside Marvel Comics and
they're not significant here but the
greys actually operate out of a casino
called area 52 every 50 yeah
every 52 in Las Vegas now the funny
thing about this is that it's like that
rule you know what happens to Vegas
stays in Vegas and if you've ever been
to Las Vegas before there's crazy people
everywhere and so like someone walking
around as an alien
no one's gonna bat an eye they just kind
of blend in perfectly what the grey
basically says is that there
a robot of course we know that now to be
recorder 451 stuck inside this
particular casino thing that looks like
a UFO and the idea is to basically break
in and steal this recorder now of course
the cool thing about this is that the
recorder is not established to be the
guaranteed way for Howard and Maria's
start to have a kid instead what happens
is the gray says hey look this robot
supposedly is like travel around the
universe and seen everything and so if
there is a way for you to achieve
whatever goal or is it you want to
achieve because you know Howard doesn't
tell the greys and he wants to advocate
or anything basically says look this
recorder would be the way for you to be
able to pull it off and so ultimately
what ends up happening is Howard Stark
assembles his own team it's kind of cool
because it's like this 1960s kind of
situation with all these different
things unfolding now keep in mind
because the fact that this is the 1960s
the Marvel Universe is still relatively
new at this point I mean in terms of
superhero immersion so like mutants are
just now showing up so things are still
relatively new in terms of how it's all
unfolding but this is kind of fun
because it turns into this sort of like
heist mission right it's kind of like
Ocean's eleven meets Marvel Comics which
I love Ocean's eleven and some I love
this kind of scenario this guy the gray
goes in and distracts the various
members of his race who are here and are
running this casino and essentially says
hey look this guy stole our robot and he
took off over to this one location and
so we have to go find him now what had
happened here is one of the guys of Tony
Stark's team used an image inducer and
basically made recorder for 51 invisible
as well as him and and Howard Stark and
so what this meant was that when the
Grays showed up inside the room where
the robot was supposed to be to their
eyes it was invisible it was it was gone
and so again this is cool because it
shows us that like some of the thievery
and stuff and like some of the schemes
are like pretty cool in terms of in
terms of the kind of stuff that they
were pulling off and so ultimately they
break it out and we actually end up
finding out that like Maria Stark Howard
Starks wife is basically like part of
the whole thieves game like she's very
much involved in this whole blackops
esque you know scenario she's a pilot
and all that stuff and so it's really
kind of cool
but again we're only given one half of
this story and the reason is because
after Tony Stark is given all this
information the recorder says there's a
lot of other things that we did a lot of
other things that we ended up getting
involved in and where Tony Stark
initially asks okay you know what
happen next what's the next stage how
does all this lead into you presumably
the birth of me the recorders also a
little kind of cloak-and-dagger here you
know where he basically says yeah this
all does kind of lead into you but we
have a destination that you're going to
and so for right now you got to go to
sleep man so we basically knocks him out
and they end up taking off to their
destination which of course turns out to
be the final battleground of the war
between the Celestials and the aspirants
and this is actually really really
really really cool it's one of the
coolest elements with regards to to this
whole thing of course we'll find out
more about that in the next video in the
meantime what we actually end up doing
is jumping back to to Howard and Maria
stark and we get the last little tidbit
of this story at least in terms of what
led into Tony's talk and what we end up
finding out here is that with them
basically kind of rescuing the recorder
the answer he gives is yes I will
definitely help you guys create a trial
now the cool thing about this is that
the recorders not doing it for
altruistic reasons there's actually a
motivation behind it and it stems
directly from the nature of the planet
Earth the recorder having traveled
around you know the cosmos for so long
and having seen so many different things
recognizes the placement of earth and
that's really the kind of case when it
comes to Marvel Comics for whatever
reason the earth is just strategically
placed in like the best possible
position when it comes to wars and
conflict and so the recorder being here
is done for the purpose of not creating
a super-powered being but creating a
person that can basically have the
intelligence to make the earth a
futurist place to look to the horizon
and find ways to basically speed up the
Earth's development in terms of weapons
technology defense systems laying the
stage for everything that would make
Tony Stark who he is and so because of
this what Recorder basically says is I'm
going to essentially give you a child
and then modify it on the genetic level
to be predisposed to a higher level of
intelligence now for any parent who's
being told we are going to make
modifications to your child before it's
born that is a terrifying concept
regardless of whether or not it's going
to benefit your child or it's going to
cause harm to your child it's a
terrifying idea and so because of that
to have genetic modifications to their
kid really just kind of freaks them out
and it really kind of bothers them a
little bit but ultimately they end up
going through with it now what we're
gonna find out is there's a little more
that was going on behind the scenes and
the way the cure in Gillen doesn't it's
absolutely genius but the fact remains
here that we end up having Maria stark
goin through the insemination process
when
child is basically bestowed inside of
her and you know six months later she
gives birth to a kid herself now this
kind of wraps up by the fact that the
Grays eventually catch up to the to the
Starks themselves and the reason why
this is so important is because the
recorder sits down and says no one can
know that this baby is here no one can
know that this child has basically been
modified by me anybody who knows about
it is going to have to be killed as far
as they're concerned they need to
believe that you have a happy and
healthy normal baby and so if the Grays
have stumbled across this and if the
Grays have realized that I is a recorder
and involved in the birth of your child
then they're going to put two and two
together and even if they don't come to
the absolute truth they're gonna become
information brokers they're gonna say a
reporter from a super-advanced race is
on earth and helping a human couple give
birth to a child it probably did
something to that kid that made it super
advanced and so again it's actually
gonna speed up the timeline of the
various races that would see the earth
as a thread and try to destroy it and so
in response Howard Stark and this
Recorder travel to this location of
where the greys are at and essentially
kill them all now Tony Stark's reaction
to this it's a lot of doubt and so
because of that is kind of a funny
situation because in this whole scenario
the recorder basically says hey look at
where you are right now you're literally
an engineer down to the genetic level
you were designed it should just be that
smart and so again it's really kind of
cool to see a lot of this changing going
on with regards to his character a lot
of this expansion be added here and so
ultimately once we get to the question
of well what happened next
after the whole scenario with the Grays
karen gillan ends the story so we will
find out in the next video what it is
that goes on further with the whole idea
of Tony Stark because where this seems
to be pretty self-explanatory and pretty
interesting on the surface when we get
in depth it's gonna get a lot more
interesting because I will say this
nothing here is as it appears to be but
with that being said guys if you are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video be sure to drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]